[موسيقى]
هذه الرياضة ستحطمك إذا تركتها ،
لقد لاحظت بعض الوجوه وكأنهم فوجئوا
برؤيتي تاريخيًا أن ناسكار هم ذكور قوقازيين
وهذا ما يفكر فيه الناس وهذا
ما يرونه في الرياضة ولا يبدو أحد على
المسار  أنا
[موسيقى]
اسمي بريانا دانيلز وأنا
أول امرأة أمريكية من أصل أفريقي يتم اختيارها
تذكر لناسكار. لم يكن لدي أي فكرة أن
هذا سيحدث ليس سبب مجيئي
إلى الرياضة ولكنني صنعت التاريخ وما
زلت أصرخ حتى  في هذا اليوم
كنت الفتاة الوحيدة ولكن في الواقع
أعطاني نوعًا ما المزيد من الحافز الذي تعرفه
لركل بأعقاب الرجال التي كنت أواجهها ،
ويجب أن أعمل مرتين بجد مثل الرجل التالي ،
يبدو الأمر كما لو كان لدي
هدفين على ظهري  وأنا أنثى ، أنا من
أصل أفريقي ، كل ما أحصل عليه من
أجل التوقفات عادة ما تتراوح
بين 10 و 14 ثانية ،
يجب على الجميع التحرك بسرعة ، فهناك
مبدل إطار أمامي ، وناقل إطار خلفي
، ورجل غاز ورجل جاك و
أنا مغير إطار خلفي
ندربه  حول الأذن لأنه يجب أن تكون لديك
هذه القوة ، لا يتعلق الأمر فقط بميكانيكا السيارات ، بل
يجب أن تكون رياضيًا
كما تعلم أننا مسؤولون حقًا عن
البحث عن هذا السائق والتأكد من
أنه جيد
في التوقف.  يجب على الجميع
أن يجتمعوا مع هذا الفريق الواحد
لإرسال سائقنا وجعله في
أيد أمينة ، مهمتي هي التأكد من أن
أكون هذا الوجه للنساء ذوات البشرة الملونة
والأولاد الصغار والفتيات الصغيرات وآمل
أن تعرف يومًا ما الناس  فكروا في
ناسكار وهم يرون أنها وجوه متعددة
وليست وجهًا واحدًا فقط عندما يستمتع الجميع
بالرياضة
[موسيقى]